what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch a
movie that I'm surprised I've never seen
myself actually 1996's twister joined by
Roxy schreier follow her at the World
Girls Channel she pressured us into
doing this hardcore just like I really
want to do twister because I'm working
with like a couple of people who worked
on twister I'm like fine shut up Roxy
it's not not what happened but it's also
not what happened she were working with
who Sean is directing and starring in
this new movie crust that I'm in and
Alan is coming to pee in it also is it
about pizza because crust no it's a
laundromat thing and crust um more like
a little more raunchy than pizza crust
question
oh crusty I got it I I got there it's a
horror comedy uh the word crust is more
about socks
leave a like if you're excited for the
movie crust upcoming with Roxy and Alan
Rick yeah Alan rock you know he's a star
of succession Ferris Bueller's Day Off
John whalen's been in everything from
Twister to Never Been Kissed stalked by
movie more full length Reaction watch
along three stick up with your own
coffee or twister available for super
sexy rejects super sexy rejects there
you go I tried to do what jaundice
[Music]
three is that what John does have you
not heard him do that oh he behaves very
different when it's you and him on
camera so I'm gonna try some bits out
with Roxy today
I'm going to entertain her today
I don't know what you're doing
the concept of this movie had me
thinking how weather negatively affects
our internet thank you to nordvpn for
sponsoring this video a digital tool
that'll have you browsing the web like
like a curious little kitty cat but
really what nordvpn is like is like
having a secret weapon that'll keep you
safe while exploring the vast wonders of
the internet think of it like a virtual
bodyguard here to protect you from all
those lurking cyber threats first things
first nordvpn is the fastest cat when it
comes to the VPN surfaces the whole
range of services at its disposal
nordvpn not only ensures your protection
but also adds a dash to convenience to
your Digital Life oh it's speaking of
protection nor VPN unleash their threat
protection feature which blocks malware
and keeps a watchful eye on the
mysterious dark web so if someone leaks
your precious credentials nor vpn's dark
web monitor will notify you they also
have your downloadables covered scans
those files for viruses faster than you
can say kitty cat and here's one of the
best parts too nordvpn lets you change
your virtual location with a single
click sometimes I just do it for fun
that means you can watch content that
might be currently unavailable in your
current region or country
there's a reason why I really believe in
the power of nordvpn I mentioned it a
few times on this channel a couple of
years ago we had a serious hacking
situation when it came to our account
and guess what we weren't using a VPN at
the time a wake-up call that led us to
swear by the importance of a solid
reliable VPN so take it from us get
yourself a nordvpn just one account can
protect up to six devices and to Sweden
the deal too nordvpn offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee for all users so
reject Nation to experience the magic of
norvpn click on the exclusive deal
linked Down Below in the pinned comment
or description box or you can just go to
visit nordvpn.com real rejects remember
it's risk-free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee so stay safe stay
secure and happy virtual Adventures my
friends
oh yes
oh yes this was a good choice
that's live that's a 90s credit sequence
of my head I love it thank me later
[Music]
69 69.
oh this this is gonna be fun
the flux capacitor yeah all right
have you ever seen a tornado in real
life yeah no have you no that'd be cool
though I'm from Boston I'm from I'm from
down the street
tornado sounds like a guttural roar
come on sweetie let's get up come on
we need to get down to the storm right
now oh that might be young Helen yeah
100 Joe's about to lose her parents yeah
parents deserve to die
oh no
I swear if this dog dies in the
beginning
no oh what a messed up movie
you did a good movie Toby so close to
Toto it's an homage Greg also the Topher
it's an homage to Mr Grace
yes and
oh I love this it's like it's a monster
whoa Papa
oh wow it's personal now that same
tornado is gonna come back in 30 years
I'm gonna kick this tornado's ass at
least he didn't die saving the dog that
would have been a cooler way to go out
no that's a Man of Steel [__] no
that is not the same thing that guy is
Superman
you know if these cells keep building
like this there could be a record
outbreak of tornadoes this is going to
be a long day what year are we now uh
present day so that would be 1996. so
from 69 to 96. yeah just flip the
numbers yeah it's uh artistic choice in
the way that you flip in a 69
so so do you get it I do I've done sex
stuff before
I know Joe she's already dragged her
entire department into the field
divorce
I got it
oops this thing is useless sorry Joe mad
about satellite
ah any TV reference you give bring it on
um
[Music]
is that Philip Seymour Hoffman all I'm
saying that's Sean John Whalen oh my God
I love both of these actors are the best
part of the movie
you did a great job there
Philip Seymour Hoffman used to play so
many characters like this this is wild
all right Joy and Bill
Paxton yeah yeah it's the biggest
serious storms in 12 years one lined up
right after another and SSL says they've
never seen anything like it this is how
they catch up about the divorce papers
oh yeah yeah yeah sure hey this shot oh
man this is the guy from Lost yeah he's
in a lot of [__] yeah
you need them right this second well
that'd be nice yes this one's the urge
and urgency act like you're getting
married I am that's a tough twist in the
heart
there you go thank you
oh she was still wearing it still
wearing what her wedding ring it's a
blue I mean no she put her non-wetting
ring on top of her
yeah good catch can I read it first no
it's the same as it was in December I
didn't read it in December Christ would
you just sign it so we can get out of
here we she's here yes she's here she's
over with Dusty go meet her bill just
told me the happy news we just wanted to
get it done before uh Billy started his
new job at weatherman what I said
weather man I think it's great yeah that
tone there was no tone if you have a
problem being a weatherman
I thought you'd be coming out here alone
I wasn't expecting on coming out here at
all you said you'd meet me at Dorothy
she's here is Dorothy the name of the
Twister uh the tornado Dorothy and Toto
never mind that's Dory
I can't believe you did it we built four
of them
cancel the divorce okay weather man hey
watch the tone Roxy whether this
was that better is better we put her up
inside a tornado and releases hundreds
of these sensors that measure all parts
of the tornado simultaneously wind
velocities flow asymmetries we could
learn more in 30 seconds they have in
the past 30 years
how do you get it in the tornado well
you got to get in front of the tornado
and put it in the damage path and then
get out again before it picks you up too
it's oh
Joe we got major action that SSL says
the cap is breaking Tower's going up 30
miles off the dry line
come on man you're getting a divorce
might as well just one last tornado
he wants to get involved it's where his
heart is yeah but Dorothy did you sign
papers oh [__] she didn't come on free
hurry we can still catch him hey Bill
glad you're back I'm not back okay Bill
keep telling yourself that darling I'll
get the paper signed and see you tonight
okay no you know what honey I find this
kind of interesting I'm gonna tag along
ah menajah
not feeling like that's the way it's
gonna go I I think that's how those
things happen
oh yeah Jonas Miller he's a night
crawler oh my God you're down the same
lab then Jonas went out and got himself
competing tornado experts I love it
wow there's also vehicular Thrills what
if we predict tornado's patch how many
lives will be spared with creation of an
early warning system the first digital
orthographic telemeter
dot three carry always let's go when
released to the tornado we'll transmit
back data on wind speed pressure what a
bunch of [__] for all study
did he punch his hat off yeah
we both know he'll never get that thing
up in the air that's right let me
Enlighten you people today we're gonna
make history because the day's a
sniffing the dirt are over he reprized
this character and say stranger things
season three it's like the exact same
character one day I'll give you one day
whether she flies or not I'm gone
honey is it is it okay oh
God so boring Melissa well he hasn't
really told me about all this if you
have to pee you should do it now because
there's not very many places to stop
once we get on the road you're so in
love with him aren't you
Melissa you became slightly interesting
okay let's move out people let's go
where are we going Melissa make yourself
useful oh she's gonna drive out no no
I knew it dumbass Melissa can't get
anything right I know she must be the
most hated character in cinematic
history
amazing coloring there isn't it
yeah look at those palmatas I bet those
tops have got to be spiking about 40
000. that's a good thing it's a very
good thing what uh something about
science
guy yes she's very nice no
she does not work at the station she's
uh she's a therapist yours Christ
look I may have walked out but at least
I showed up in the first place
commitment like stability supportiveness
in a house dude can I drive no then
would you
whoa
vehicular action it was wild that was
such a 90s movie moment
wow it would be so cool to see this
tornado
sure not for people who've actually seen
this tornado they would say that
three miles Southeast let's see what she
does
whoa that looks great for 96 damn that
looks very real go in there hurry
second
that's your nerve
tighten your seat belt
that was hot for some reason
[Music]
damn holy [__] this plant is ridiculous
you let her provoke you
that is a terrify accident what is the
plan here they gotta let it get caught
into it the the Earth
thank you
they're just gonna stay right there
that's terrible idea
what are you doing
what do you want to see it's her
childhood trauma Greg she needs therapy
wow
no way they would not get caught up in
that
oh they were totally get caught up in
that I don't even know how a tornado
works but I know they get caught him we
don't know
where's my truck
yes do it
oh God I'm okay let's try she's
screaming she's horrified she's
traumatized you could understand Helen
hunts well I want to look at the tornado
up close but you can't understand this
yes
analyze me later all right yeah so
something more about you the Auto Club's
here
ah
these snakes come on guys let's get
Dorothy two ready we got full coverage
on that truck liability only it's a very
pretty truck
thank you
[Laughter]
again
but back there you almost got yourself
oh no just a close call you're gonna
cross 15 at Oklahoma 4-1-2
cinema four one two baby
what are you doing what are you doing
cut through the field look at the
updraft the angle
it's gonna shift his track it'll move
left is that bad wasn't there a road
back there you're right go go go go go I
do like how they used Melissa to be the
audience yeah
are you sure
it's moving away I know it feels
unnatural but with Donald's motility
you're not gonna have to save the
old-fashioned way she's a reproductive
therapists
gotta have American Heroes
I really do like how they capture the
Twister like it's a like it's a Monster
yeah it's really cool well it is scary
as hell yeah I know I bet I still am
unclear on how they're planning on
getting this in they gotta put it in the
path so it just sucks it up in the past
right but like if you were gonna do that
it feels like the car situation was the
perfect situation to do that yeah that's
what I thought happened yeah but
apparently not
because they didn't like unleash it when
she went to go back to try to you have
to do something it like spit out
apocalypse
there's double the tornadoes
okay we got sisters
what's a water tornado called probably
just that yeah you probably nailed it
cyclon oh maybe yeah I'm not sure
oh get off the phone Melissa
no the cow oh wait I think I've seen
that image before
oh [__]
wow what a terrifying situation
okay
sweat
is safe
have you seen Smallville
yeah celebrate with your wife your
actual wife put your arm around do they
get it up are they celebrating because
they did it I think they're celebrating
because they survived okay
it's okay no I'm not okay
oh Christ I'm sorry you used to tell me
that you chased tornadoes deep down I
was just I was a metaphor
[Laughter]
like skeletons in your closet that was a
metaphor some of us couldn't help but
notice how close we are to Wakita guys
we are not in
[Applause]
their dog and her mom well I think the
dog probably died because it's been like
almost 30 years in a severe lightning
storm you want to grab your ankles and
stick your butt in here okay if you're
gonna get hit it's the safest orifice
yeah I'd like to get hit by lightning
Watts you know true you could ask him
when you see him on set what was it an
F3 solid F2 it's the Fujita Scale it
measures the intensity of a tornado by
how much it eats encounter meat back
there's a strong F2 F3 maybe but we see
someone for us today is there an F5
oh Melissa it's took her dad none of you
have ever seen left five oh they will
today she has just one of us yeah
oh what a good moment there's a lot of
good actors in it mostly Alan and Sean
they'll they're the best he didn't keep
his part of the bargain
to spend his life pining for you and die
miserable and alone got so much to ask
Helen Hunt is really good in this movie
yeah she's great Bill always went his
own way which was usually the same way
you were going it seems like a long time
ago
tear
is he there to get divorce papers
there's so many goddamn tornadoes you
better run
yeah
it's the dog it's Dorothy grown-up no
the dog's name was Toto Toto no you said
it sounded like Topher and I said it
sounded like Toto it was a tobo toddy
Teddy
ah [__] let us know Tata ask them when
you see the monster
Bill trust me rabbit is good gravity is
wives great line delivery excels at
every line he delivers agreed
you see that brush right in front of you
what's beyond that it's the highway it's
the highway
where's the road rabbit yeah where's the
road man it should be any moment whoa
[Applause]
whoa
oh my God you're insane Joe what are you
trying to do get somebody killed
it was right okay
they threw down for these like Chase the
tornado sequences yeah we're gonna have
to get off of this road but this is no
time to guess I'm not guessing just make
a right turn trust me do you want to
drive just turn
he's gonna be a great weather man looks
like he's coming down room 33. what's
the path uh it's going about 35 miles an
hour
okay let's see this
can't see it I believe that he couldn't
see it yeah me too you see it no you got
anything out there North Northeast
[__] is coming right at us do you see it
no no he already said he didn't see it
where's Melissa
um slowly dying on the inside time for
deployment guys let's do it oh man this
is the fun part sweetheart
no why she was getting stuck with him if
I was her you don't marry him now when
someone shows you who they are believe
them and he's neglecting her Sanders
pull it over anywhere
so many weather choices yeah I'm pretty
sure Sean told me the movie was delayed
months because of all the actual weather
stuff oh and they need to actually
control how it how they shoot it yeah
some good sound design in this movie
damn so they're finally gonna do it
you guys are insane we need we know they
have four of these we know they've gone
through two now
right so this is the third yes so
thematically this won't work because we
need to get to the fourth thematically
or like
plot wise not thematically the opposite
of thematically
expositionally sure
structurally structure
[Music]
if this is three what's four or five
it's the shape of a Kaiju monster
[Music]
I love in movies when they say things
like a hurry it's like yeah no [__]
[Music]
it wouldn't work even if they just let
it take the truck I don't think he wants
to lose his truck liability
[Music]
oh
no no not Dorothy
oh no no no no
Dorothy no
Dorothy where is it oh my God it's gonna
come from another spot
I don't believe this so late to getting
it because Dorothy got sucked into the
tornado
I just put that together well Dorothy
she's okay she lives yeah but she in The
Wizard of Oz she goes into her tornado
what kind of isn't that how she gets to
Oz
we don't need to go over this right now
yeah and then she wakes up yeah I think
it knocks her out I don't think she gets
sucked up well there's still a turtle I
know something hits her
she goes in the cellar she's running
away
it is too late honey she needs to
understand what took her parents her dad
what are you doing
oh you've never seen him miss this house
and miss that house and come after you
Joe things go wrong you can't explain it
you can't predict it killing yourself
won't bring your dad back
sorry he died but it was a long time ago
gotta move on it's a great radio stop
living in the past and look at what you
got right in front of you solid radio
connection oh my God the mic on it I
love love though
that was such a beautiful moment oh I'm
sorry Melissa but you're not it honey
you're not it when it's not you it's not
you it's been not me for many times I
know it sucks but it's not you it's not
you do you know how many guys Roxy has
lost because of their obsession with
tornadoes yeah and the woman from the
tornado
the list goes on and on
whoa what a weird shining what the hell
it is The Shining
oh she gotta sign the divorce papers
Roxy as she should you don't you don't
want to trap anybody in anything they
don't want to be in nah well that's your
opinion
okay love is love that's what I say
you know I've been thinking about the
sensors the way they scattered out there
today on the highway I'm starting to
wonder whether the funnel will carry him
like we thought too late I don't know
maybe the whole thing's too light
you talking about Melissa being too
light he's rethinking
now it's serious yeah let's take a TV
television
the five the five is come for your
here's Johnny
it's
already here everybody underground now
how fun it would be to deliver lines
like that
[Music]
sick great shot everybody
ouch oh that was sliced your face up
damn
I love the sets
it's like the Universal Studios
holy [__] I'm not saying I wouldn't be
her but I hope I wouldn't be here
Melissa yeah screaming at the top of
your lungs just like treating it like
she's the only one
no do not take my ant
oh my God they're really gonna do this
that's cruel what is the end goal here
of this movie they're gonna like learn
what the tornado is yeah I was just
thinking that because we still have to I
think we still have like almost a half
hour don't we yeah I think so can you
tell which way it's headed
back in Northeast it looks to hit Wakita
head on I'm going let's go away
you don't have your Dorothy sensor [__]
though no she does she's gotta go to her
aunts I'm going back good good he'll be
safe at the motel I'll see you in the
morning
I won't be there I I can't compete with
this wait don't do this now please
terrible timing
she's right I love her now best
character in the movie yep you go ahead
she needs you what about you don't worry
about me I know my way home now she dies
it's okay because yeah I still think
they should kill her off yeah me too but
I now like her I'll now feel sad yeah
they rounded out all the Loose Ends that
we needed them to to feel good about it
like she signed the paper so we know
she's not trapping him they ended anyway
with Melissa like you know
all the things that we needed Spielberg
did a great job directing that moment I
know it's philbrick is an excellent
director Josephina spilbert knew what
she was doing
[Music]
no
joke take a flashlight the dog
dog's alive we gotta get this off over
hang on oh God okay ready watch your
hand watch it go go why do you think
they made this character her aunt
instead of her mom I'm not sure
yikes you gotta hurry let's go take a
good walk
whoa
[Applause]
great
though he practiced where's the dog
you're going to the hospital
honey your car's in a tree around the
corner
oh
honey
I don't even know if you want to know
but I it's it's happened in NSS self
predicting an F5 you go stop it
you do
stop it
he's telling her to go do the thing
because they have one left
I know how to make Dorothy fly
okay
plane
Superman I think if you take a plane you
drop it from above oh your guess was
real or Dominic Toretto would just zoom
right past through it come out the other
end and tornado I need every aluminum
can
you cutters
so I want to get the last door in the
back of my truck and I want to get them
both on there right now he was able to
see what she wanted to do without
aluminum cans that's love
I would take an aw a root beer
a decade
I haven't had real soda in a long time
what's fake soda sparkling water so like
bubblies
that was the Sabbath sentence you've
ever said they're delicious they are
good just to satisfy this is how they're
able to pay for this whole movie yeah
that one Pepsi scene
Dusty you ready for us yeah yeah we're
good
do you know what they're doing they need
to make them fly because they said they
were too light they weren't going up oh
yeah so whatever those windmill like
yeah so was not a metaphor for Melissa
could have been I figure put it right in
the middle of the road I think somebody
will hit it nobody will be there
somebody will hit it he's gonna drive
like all right let's go
the actual twister scenes are really
well done yeah
it's real like suspense
it was a lot simpler than any of the
other times
it's got to go wrong right Carrie Elvis
foreign
oh [__]
whoa
oh
my god oh I got goosebumps
did she say what is that yeah
I believe it's a tornado
oh shoot
damn oh no they do that
[Music]
oh they're in it now oh you can't
survive at F5
whoa
whoa jeez nice
way to go bill this monster still moving
Northeast on Eddie this is it
last one I thought that we were on the
last one all right no there's another
one in there yeah I saw it but remember
they said they had four
it's beautiful
Carrie go away as you wish
you did it you made it work marriage
okay path is stable copy that hello
you get my father prepare to die that's
what she's saying to the Twister yeah
that is true you killed my father
prepare to die
Jonas what's your position we are
heading Northeast running parallel and
about to pull ahead of it on the left
why hang back a minute we got a pretty
good view from back here she could shift
her Dragon if she does she's gonna come
right after it when I want your opinion
I'll give it to you when I want your
opinion I'll give it to you
listen to me this is not get off this
frequency Bill she's shifting
oh so they're going to be the ones who
die
right for him
eliminated the competition
for 96 this looks awesome it looks
amazing still looks better than a lot of
movies that today
I think they have some of the actual
items they're destroying
drive right through it do it movie so he
said it looks like we're going yeah
that's what I'm talking about
oh hell yeah
oh that was sick I love it let me just
set the cruise control
okay we're good
oh they're gonna jump out of the car
like you suggested at the beginning yeah
man just how are you gonna get away from
the tornado
I don't know
why are they staying that long
time ago
you both could have he had it on cruise
control yeah there's no point of you
guys staying in there
oh yeah
little fireflies
[Music]
sure wreck some more houses
there's just no way like should you like
dig a hole in the ground that will not
do anything hold on to the leaves
I would not want to be in a tornado
position with you rocks
right
[Music]
oh my God like the beginning is there an
underground
[Music]
[Laughter]
like does the house even slow it down
oh my God
where are we
good thing it's unlocked
we out here too we might have a chance
we're gonna hang on to the pipes
they're gonna tie themselves to the
pipes yep smart
oh my God I feel like pipes break all
the time not in this situation nope not
when it's Bill
while they're in the middle of it they
should have just kept Dorothy on them
like a great look
we're gone in that house
I do wonder if that pipe thing actually
will work in real life total [__]
Dorothy really flew I gotta get Grant
approval for a new warning system you've
got to start analysis and all that data
I do yeah we got to generate models out
of all this dead and I need to run the
limbs I'm a weatherman I'm running the
lab you're right I don't think so do you
always have to do things the hard way
damn it Dusty and friends if you pull up
and your friends are alive you're
probably stoked we've seen enough
everyone's like well what about Melissa
man I feel like that leather strap would
have ripped through them probably that'd
be gory
now I'm just making out
Jen the bunt directed it
back who's John de Bond oh my God
Michael Crichton wrote did you know
Michael Crichton is who is that he's the
writer of a Jurassic Park he wrote the
book
and he wrote the book for Westworld
Steven Spielberg oh that makes sense
his name sounds familiar I don't like
that you quizzed me but I will accept it
okay
[Laughter]
oh my God Helen Hunt's top billing over
Bill Paxton
it's rare for a 90s movie for that to be
the case that's why I was asking how old
she is here because I feel like she was
very established at this point I mean
she's a really
um prominent character she's like
force in this movie if this uh came out
today people would call awoke but back
then it's just a movie hmm it's an
actual movie who's John the bomb
Jean the bunt
oh my god dude what do you think that
post-crediting will be F6 yeah for sure
we got some awesome [__] coming our way
what is the sequel to this gonna be it's
called twisters
but this had multiple also kind of kind
of like split apart I don't know I love
rock oh above Philip Seymour Hoffman
deservedly so
really good I gotta say um we put this
movie on for your Jake Busey who was
Jake Busey in this movie who's Jake
Busey I didn't want to quiz you
very Gary Busey yeah it's Gary Busey's
son
well
okay that makes sense yeah bud Carr yeah
music supervisor and you ever we both
know music supervisors very well and uh
there's a lot of cars in the movie there
was a lot of cars so many cars
everybody was willing to lose like
thirty thousand fifty thousand dollars
and this in the name of science so we
watched this whole hour and 45 minute
movie uh because your two friends are in
it and they were not in it that much I
said that to you you didn't say they
weren't in that much I did you not once
you never once paid for a tradition
Lockhart uh you know once matched to me
I mean a joke right now you never said I
said I said I don't think that they're
in it that much they're part of like a
gang and then I told you that they were
on game and then I said they were on set
for a long time even though they weren't
in it that much because of the weather
thing
you don't listen to me
I might need to repeat all that and I
feel like they were in it a lot more
than I thought they were going to be
um they weren't a lot more than you
thought they were going to be oh my God
oh my gosh all right you you win I lose
you're smart I'm dumb you're big I'm
small and there's nothing you can do
about it you ever see Matilda no it was
on my list for movies to react
okay well and you won't understand
um okay well I still enjoyed the movie
Roxy lay down your opinions please I
thought it was good I mean it just seems
[__] huge yes I was surprised with
how big this movie is
because frankly I had never heard of it
before they were talking about it
you murdered twister before they were
talking about it no
but Sean was talking about it a few
years ago when I did this show with him
and I was like maybe I saw it I guess I
hadn't
but now well why is this known as a big
big movie yeah it's a huge movie
I thought it was gonna be boring I was
like what do I care about a twister for
about one tornado I thought it was like
one tornado
and Helen Hunt so you liked it more than
you thought I liked it a lot more than I
thought I was going to this is this is
Hollywood fun at its finest it's Alan
Rock Sean Whalen I know Bravo Sanders
just the appropriate amount of screen
time
um yeah oh Anthony rap yeah the hell
with him huh yeah he's awful awful guy
do we not like him Rusty swimmer no
Anthony rap is not an awful guy who's
that the one who accused Kevin Spacey of
oh my God he's a great guy I don't know
I don't pay attention enough to these
things Roxy
I think you were here [__] correctly
I was like are we friends with those
guys
took down my show
um
okay okay
um are you doing the music I thought the
music was great
what I liked too is the choice to mainly
not use Music whenever they were in
there like up close to the tornado
sequence a bit like they just let the um
the destruction be the the atmosphere of
the destruction be be the entire mood
for it is feel the space
um yeah I'm genuinely con uh not
confused but like I just don't know why
we set up a movie I think this movie is
very well done
plot wise not theme wise why did we set
up a movie in which her mom and dad and
dog are with her in the bunker the dad
dies the mom lives
and then instead of having her mom be
the character that comes back it's the
aunt
um yeah no I mean I don't have an answer
for you I mean maybe because she looked
enough like it could have been the mom
right maybe because it's a symbolism for
she lost everything cuts out a lot of
conversation that she would have to have
with her mom there's a song in here by
Stevie Nicks called Twisted I love it
um produced by Lindsay Buckingham yeah
not an awful person
um yeah it was
I said Red Hot Chili Peppers let's go
um I thought I heard it at one point but
uh can you hear your band huh Goo Goo
Dolls Goo Goo Dolls yeah it's a lot of
familiar John Resnick this is a this is
a needle drop Galore here my God
um yeah I I thought
this is great
Eddie Van Halen and Alex Van Halen
all that Warner Brothers music
when you've got money honey
so yeah I don't know why they set it up
but I think you know to keep her
completely alone that way when she's
having that whole spiel
now that's why they did it because when
she's having that whole thing with Bill
Paxton
to make to drive home that no one could
understand what she's feeling and go
like there's literally no one and
therefore where's her mom and if her
mom's dead and because her mom oh did
did they say that I mean unless she's a
total dick and doesn't bother to visit
her mom it's her and all this I mean
maybe the mom moved away or whatever but
they never acknowledge that the mom died
right I think it's safe to assume the
mom died in the Twister not in the
Twister but um later on
at post twister probably I imagine some
kind of
diabetic condition she had that she had
to go through I don't think so
let's see what twisters is
okay
I don't I think it's just more Twisters
but with Helen Hunt I don't think she's
gonna be in it oh
Twisters movie let's do this 2024 is
coming everything we know
okay everything we know and then I want
to see who direct the person who
directed this with else the director do
whatever you want Roxy
sassafras
when is Twisters releasing July 19 2024
all right so um when the Twister trailer
comes out will you be here at six
o'clock in the morning to cover it with
us I got you all right thanks
do we know the plot a twister oh my God
that's what I made it for plot
details are scarce Universal plan is
close to the vest I like it just I mean
sorry
new chapter in the franchises world I
hope they have spin-offs the film is
expected to center around the daughter
of the iconic characters played by Han
hunt and Bill Paxton uh well Bill
Paxton's passed away so he can't return
hella hunka come back
the daughter hmm
yeah
I could play Helen Hunt's daughter okay
sure
yeah why not the lack of confidence you
just had wow
I don't know I said yeah sure
yeah what did I do to piss you off today
sat through twists
I want to see John the bomb
all right it's a good shot to bond or it
could be yawn de Bond or it could be
jammed Bond oh my if it's a guy I would
say Yonder Bond
oh he directed Speed oh it's totally a
guy I thought it was a woman
um speed's a good one he's a Roman
Catholic Dutch just like Steven
Spielberg
um Roman Catholic yes oh and then he
produced Minority Report that's
interesting which is a
Eid
oh these mainly oh my God he's the
director of photographer only the weapon
so he's a cinematographer mainly that's
why this looks so sick oh it is DP for
Die Hard oh yeah not at all it all shows
Hunt for Red October some great movies
he's worked on Basic Instinct he got
that famous shot good for him he's
growled so fast I read fast man
um I'm sorry and his birthday is October
22nd which likely means he's a Scorpio
oh yeah I don't know that at all I just
know nothing
it's likely means birthday falls close
to Halloween if I'm not mistaken that's
true
um
where do you find that uh director let's
see what else he's directed let's do
this oh my God directed uh the sequel to
Laura Croft Tomb Raider the Cradle of
Life the superior what is the haunting
The Haunting is a classic that stars
Catherine Zeta Jones
and I believe Liam Neeson I want us when
you start talking it sounded like you
didn't know but you did 100 right oh
Bruce Dern I love him Owen Wilson
wow ghost also directed Speed to cruise
control that's like speed but on a
cruise
it's a good one this is cool yeah I know
he's cool I but I thought the movie was
a lot more fun than I expected it to be
I think nowadays movies like this
contact themselves I hope Twisters
doesn't take itself too serious I
thought this had the right amount of
taking itself serious enough like enough
to give a [__] about Helen Hunt and Bill
Paxton I thought Helen Hunt was great
she was so good in this and it was
actually refresh I was totally expecting
her to be supporting Woman character and
she was the real lead of the movie to me
yeah for sure at first I was like oh am
I gonna have a I like her but am I gonna
have an issue because she just will not
let this guy get a divorce and he wants
one and that's like to me a problematic
character choice but then when she signs
and you know she just need a little
extra time well that's why they boringed
up you know Melissa to make you go God
this one was a borer yeah and she was
she was she was terribly do you think
she survived I hope not in my in my head
Canon she died on the way back to her
home she says oh I know how to get
myself home and I was like what what is
that even a reference to do you
imagine she drove home got caught up in
a tornado survived but came out terribly
damaged and then Carrie Elvis ran her
over on the way to the F5 tornado
crushed her skull in terribly
bummer yeah but you know she kind of had
it coming for just being a that happens
very boring
um speaking of Catherine Zeta John she
had it coming she had it coming she had
it coming
um yeah Phil Paxton was good yeah he is
very good they played off of each other
very well I believe
it wasn't like Hollywood she's 20 and he
is 60. yeah because look up how old she
was I'm really curious let's do some
math here for the constant questions
that Roxy has so she's born in 1963. oh
my God I was close she's she was 33 when
the movie came out so she must have been
31 when they filmed it huh
you said she looked much older that's
sexist I didn't say much you said she
looked a lot older you said no she looks
a little you don't pay attention to me
you literally said Dwight do you think
she looks older and I said yeah you said
a little thick in the face is what you I
believe you said yeah and I thought like
that's a little mean no it's just so
hard when people have been stuck I don't
know if you have this problem but people
have been stars for so many years they
like stay looking the same so it's hard
to know hair transplants um and I was
trying to figure out like okay so what
had Helen done at this point I would
have guessed that she was like
37 38 in this ouch no why ouch no
because she clearly looked much younger
than that Helen Hunt is married to Hank
Azaria
yeah everyone knows that I did not know
that
are they oh no they don't divorced
one whole year so will you IMDb here for
a second what did she do before this oh
mad about you that episode of Friends
where she carried over a character from
Mad about you but this is then this must
be before she did um later on she did
what that's what I was going to say was
this that was her husband later
don't hit me with the great actors great
actors okay
if you say so
why is there someone in there that's
problematic
[Music]
not if you have certain beliefs oh you
know what oh someone wants to install my
Man of Steel movie but will not go to
town on article review
without a certain actor
let's see Mel Gibson
um I love you Daddy
so as good against was the next year oh
yeah friends of two years before she won
an Oscar for okay so she hadn't done as
much before this no
interesting yeah wow so this was like
her big big screen
wow she crushed this then she really had
a commanding presence and like just was
so really wait that is bizarre to me
right how no what about you must have
been before
but that's a show
was Bill Paxton nobody before
this is kind of crazy I mean Mad About
You must have been like a huge ass show
then for her to be doing this you mean
yeah yeah
totally totally I mean she's so so
delete yeah in a huge Blockbuster what
was the budget on there's top billing
okay yeah
I mean we start with her so it makes
sense that she was top billing it was
her backstory she's the protagonist yeah
92 million dollars for inflation and to
be like like 200 million dollars for
inflation it looked really good they did
a really really good job with this
effects hold up still amazingly like I
love sets where the Practical effects
are on like really shown like the the
destruction of the houses the debris and
all the all the houses toppled over and
stuff I thought that all looked great
and um I thought it had a real it had
some genuine fun to it it was exciting
like had an excitement to it it was kind
of like the same structure all the time
you know like yeah chase the tornado try
to get the internet fail yeah
destruction take a little breather they
set it up at the beginning like there's
four of them so you know how many and
we're waiting for a five and whatever
like you kind of knew all that this is
interesting last minute reshoots in
March and April to clarify a scene about
Joe as a child and overtime requirements
during post-production of Twister
Spielberg took over directing duties on
Minority Report instead of The Haunting
oh interesting and then he went on to
the yeah hunting instead do you think
that was like a gentleman's like all
right you do this I'll do this okay yeah
oh how funny wow Minority Report is one
of my favorites that's pretty I'm glad
he took over for that me too I love that
movie it's an amazing film
um yeah that was cool
Philip Seymour Hoffman was in it fun
supporting creepy guy yeah your friends
what are their names again oh my God
what is brought up with you Alan rock
Alan Rock Sean Whalen Shawn Wayland oh
I'll commit to memory
I I wish Alan Rock was my friend he's
not your friend I'm gonna try
well this is gonna go up after you try
okay so we'll see so let me know if I
need to cut something out okay you guys
I will remove anything that is
complementary towards him if he does not
treat you nice no no I met him the other
day it was lovely he's just not I just
don't think he'd call me a friend yet
yeah well you gotta climb that ladder
the operative word
thematically speaking I think friendship
is there
plot line
perhaps not that's the Journey of your
character right there with Alan Ruck yep
oh my God thank God I got his name right
um you know he's very very um he's known
yeah I know he's well known
um who's your little friend who's your
little buddy we're supporting yeah yeah
yeah I have I I have a Funko Pop of me
and that's all made
um as a gift not like you know I have an
official Funko Pop but they took the
Cameron Funko Pop and then they
converted it to like my hair and stuff
but they took it from camera why was
that the one they used for you I have no
idea but that was the one they used
how'd you know because they told me
that's what they did that's cool I said
sweet so apparently I look like your
friend your best friend Alan Ruck I just
call him Al oh I call him AI I don't
know why the eye is there AR
um I'll be still shorter than
um
do you have anything else you want to
add no just that this was good I am
excited that I don't have to lie to them
when I tell them that I watched it today
and they say how did you like it and I
can say that was really really solid
that's how I almost felt about this
movie called Always Lola
you're you're the shots fired today I
haven't seen you removed your movie
all right I feel bad I actually haven't
seen them
I know how proud you are of that people
say it's really good
I've heard him private who's people you
know friends of friends like Roxy's
actually good in the movie thanks
appreciate that
um pretty decent I try to watch it
it was it was then some random Festival
like Marina Del Rey and you didn't come
it was in July this year
are you stating that because we weren't
as close in July
no no no no no
it's not July yet
all right I said I was going to come
that's why that's why I messed up
there's one happening right I thought
you have I thought you have it playing
no it happened it already happened last
July oh
oh yeah I didn't I don't know I think I
knew you then did I know you
I didn't know you said like October
right
because we were besties yet we didn't
really know each other I would see you
like in passing it like Throwdown events
I think it well I'll keep everybody
posted on how they can see it but
hopefully soon
okay cool I'll react to it right here oh
my God every time you show up on screen
we'll go that would be crazy I would do
a reaction with you I'd be so
self-conscious you would be I'd be
selfish I would be I'd be like so where
you're next to me and be like this is
weird does this make you feel more
confident that you could live through a
twister because I'm actually now no
longer afraid yeah I can handle the
Twister man kick that Twister's ass
totally yeah me too bro get my pistol I
was like totally like win the game of
twists I do strap myself some pipes how
hard is that get my belt I really feel
like that leather
let's do this I feel like all of our
review was in the reaction how
unrealistic is twister
and it says do you mean how realistic
interesting but is it scientifically
accurate
okay Fox Weather what do you got yeah
and you push your agendas huh
he was a weatherman
try to give me a vote a certain way oh
come on load internet I need to find out
yeah which which uh side of the aisle is
pro twister
laughs
oh God that is the cool thing about
natural disasters which is a sentence I
don't say often yeah I say at least once
a week nobody's down
uh dodo uh God
huh twister okay
Kathleen Kennedy produces Star Wars
um I don't see
if it's scientifically accurate I just
want like a a quick answer I just want
something that's just like it's twister
and acne
it was actually based on the work of
scientists at noaa's national severe
storms laboratory there was no way you
could survive a lot of that [__] that
they survived though no way don't
believe it no it's just the Running part
oh my God you can't run that yeah no
that's [__] no no way but Alan Ruck
could uh run it and so can Sam Wilson
what's his name Wilson Sam Wilson okay
Sean Whelan
he's literally directing my movie oh my
god dude and the movie crust is gonna be
incredible it's about a laundry piece of
uh chain
yes all righty I wish you listened to me
I did listen
Pete's uh crusts is the laundry
laundromat and there's gross stuff it's
a horror comedy
I just don't remember names
took me forever to be like oh Roxy short
for Roxanne
good
how is it like that
what does your name mean was it mean
Rock Solid
I don't get the question what is what
does your name mean
like why was I named it
holy crap how is this a hard question
what is the meaning of your name in like
a different language you mean
well I don't know what you mean just
like the general like what does the name
Roxanne mean I've never been asked that
before nor do I think it has a
is right there
so you wanted the Greek origins of my
name you have a is there another meaning
to your name I don't think my name has a
meaning it says it right here when you
type it in
Persian origin
where the name originates from it
originates it's a Persian origin name
okay and it means Dawn
did you not know this I I still don't
even know what you're talking about
Alan rock is gonna have a very hard time
becoming your friend
I don't think he's gonna ask me where my
name I was named after the sting in the
police song Roxanne were you
legitimate your name yes okay
okay so maybe that song was that would
be the answer to why you were named
Roxanne okay like I was named Greg
because of my uncle you you know what
Greg means Gregory means Vigilant and
watchful in what I don't know where it
comes from but that's what the original
originator of my name cheese
you're taking the fun out of Twister
[Music]
meaning flock
yes such ties Grant Greg this you were
the flock stature of a Shepherd yeah you
guys at home let us know how many of you
know what your name means and if you
don't Google it it's interesting what do
mine mean uh Dawn
it's Persian alrighty guys like me well
let us know your thoughts down below be
sure to subscribe leave a like go watch
our Prince of Egypt reaction not as much
hate as I thought but a decent amount
just what I like to see
um before we go Roxy can you help me do
a patreon of the day shut up
back to all you Pages this one goes out
to one very specific Patron out there
Daniel Kelly
who would be amazing to give a shout out
to also you've got share in your name
and the Cher is the Queen of All Things
Scottish and also I would let her
prescribe me anything just like you
Daniel
thanks thanks for you patreon
um what language was or what accent was
that I don't know I I couldn't think of
Scottish you started Irish okay what's
Scottish you know when we started
messing around on like when we were just
like warming up for the camera earlier
you were doing a Scottish accent what
did I say
um I'm best friends with Alan o'broke
[Laughter]
I love me some Alan Rock
uh I can't do Scottish accents I bet you
sound way Doper than I do I did it
earlier it came over me like like the
dawn
nicely done yeah no seriously super sexy
reject Daniel thank you
thank you I hope you appreciated that
all right this video is official
Irish and you went British
right
person
[Music]